tellement d'avenir eve oui gérard auteur
d'une carte nous sommes prêts et nous
nous joignons à vous pour demander à
tous ceux qui sont près d'un téléphone
allait allez-y tendez le bras fait le
numéro 36 37 et puis dé nous et puis
découvrez dans un nouvel comment peut-on
dire dans un mouvement et par tour dans
un nouvel emploi j'ose plus gerra unis
solide a fait la voix de nicole touriste
que man devient brésilien cette offense
bac et il est couvert d'or ça tombe bien
en l'occurrence il est accompagné par
anne marie fontaine gérard holtz
je suis président y ait de l'eau rayonne
de rio janet est riche aujourd'hui qu'un
accaparé je te le vient encore de foyers
soit venu déjà y avait de l'inde en mots
valises des diamants à ma chemise
première a duré tout cela le temps
d'avoir deux cents amis et des mets 4 5
m à 6 mois de galan deux ivres et puis
puis un pari pari aussi moi tu m'as tout
raflé et puis vers ma jeune la mairie du
mas pourrait mélancolie délicatement
remballer mais je peux les deux le venir
et la bâtiment ciel sauvagement les
[ __ ] avec l'âge une autre phase du no
mori je ne suis pas magie de gagner
quand le mal des sommes folles et je
viens pour que tu me donnes tout ce que
la bâche et volé
tout ce que là bas j'ai volé
je suis plus il y un jeu de l'horrible
de rayonnages aujourd'hui que naguère
par et je te revient encore je suis
brésilien j'ai de l'eau fait jamais de
rio john parry paris parly paris je dors
revient ce temps là je viens de
débarquer mettez vos fourches de
cocottes comme la nouvelle poule à
j'apporte à vos quenottes tout une
fortune croquer le pigeon vient plus mes
plumes et poney mais dans l'âme et ben
notamment de motion mes potes du mois de
mai
ils suivent les îliens jacques delors il
y arrive de rayonnages aujourd'hui que
n'égale paris je te revient encore je
suis président y injectant dans les gens
les druides geoffroy vis ma vie paraît
pas les gens travers d'antan
merci à marie j'ai beaucoup travaillé
les calmars et concarneau
vous pouvez l'applaudir très très fort
parce que c'est très difficile à chanter
et je vais appeler tout le monde auprès
de moi pour le final 1 allez on termine
en terminant il faut terminer parce que